a line that was very on Wednesday what
was written in the script that was
ultimately mixed keep watching to find
out Netflix managed to close the year
with another massive streaming hit in
its Wednesday series directed by Tim
Burton and based on The Adams Family
Outsider teenager Wednesday Adams played
by Jenna Ortega the humorous series got
off to a record-breaking start before
continuing to shatter another Netflix
record a mere week after its debut the
show is equal parts team comedy and TV
mystery as Wednesday navigates life at
Nevermore Academy her family's alma
mater it's a show full of Supernatural
hijinks neat callbacks to Wednesday's
spooky family and of course a memorable
dance scene that has spawned numerous
social media copycats but one of the
series real shining points is Ortega's
performance as the titular Wednesday
Ortega's portrayal of the young goth
student has earned erupting Applause
from many viewers many fans believe
Ortega tried to embody the character
that fans grew up no while providing her
own Spin and ultimately her portrayal is
a unique balance that offers a character
full of natural Charisma despite her
often grim and sardonic interactions
Ortega put in so much work to get the
character right yet her attempts to be
the best possible version of Wednesday
also included saying no to one out of
character line in a Tick-Tock clip of
Netflix q a with Jenna Ortega the actor
noted a particular time when she felt
she had to take out a line that might
have felt out of character the line
concerns the black prom dress that Tyler
ultimately buys for her according to
Ortega there was supposed to be some
dialogue concerning the dress but she
nixed it feeling that it may not have
fit or take a set in the clip I remember
there's a line where like I'm talking
about a dress and initially she was
supposed to say oh my God I'm freaking
out over a dress I literally hate myself
and I was blown away because that
sounded like it was just a bunch of
little things like that I felt like we
were able to avoid a lot of dialogue in
an attempt to make her sound human fans
may recall that Wednesday's reaction to
the dress in the series is more of a
subtle smile which seems more fitting
than the proposed dialogue and where
Wednesday's Outsider Vibes come off as
authentic the dialogue would have felt
more like the character trying too hard
clearly Ortega's understanding of her
character is proof of her dedication to
getting the part right the overwhelming
success of Wednesday can largely be
attributed to Jenna Ortega's infectious
and authentic performance which doesn't
seek to replicate previous iterations of
The Addams Family character in an
interview with complex Ortega made it
very clear that it would be moot to
replicate Christina ricci's take on the
character which was first seen on the
big screen in 1991 Ortega told the
outlet you want to do something
different you don't want to be ripping
off anybody else's performance she added
that Wednesday is the first time
audiences are getting such an intimate
look into the character's life making it
important to add Dimension to her for
Ortega playing The Addams Family
character is a balancing act as she has
to both respect where the characters
come from but also offers something new
especially for younger audiences who may
not be familiar with Wednesday she added
I was very protective and I never wanted
to give too much or too little the
Wednesday actress clearly cares for the
character and has made it a point to
make her take on the goth Superstar as
authentic and modern as possible